[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal nous sommes le
lundi 6 décembre voici les titres de
cette édition
valérie pécresse sera candidate aux
élections présidentielles
élu au congrès les républicains ce
samedi face à eric ciotti la candidate
prépare à présent sa campagne pour 2022
au focus sur la fin pour l'étiquette
dans ce journal la construction du
centre aqualudique de maurepas élan pour
se poursuit un chantier implantée à la
place de l'ancienne piscine mort d'asia
la première pierre des bassins a été
posée symboliquement ce lundi et puis le
téléthon a eu lieu ce week end objectif
récolter des fonds pour financer la
recherche contre les maladies rares
plusieurs événements étaient organisés
dans le département retour sur cette 35e
édition
le vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines devrait ouvrir d'ici une
dizaine de jours selon jean michel
fourgous président de l'agglomération de
sky l'objectif raccourcirait les délais
pour se faire vacciner si le centre de
saint quentin en yvelines avaient été
maintenus ouverts pour 500 vaccination
vaccinations par jour environ ils
devraient réinvestir leurs centrales du
vélodrome pour revenir à sa capacité
maximale de trois mille doses par jour
en moyenne
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre valérie
pécresse et la candidat des républicains
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 la présidente de la région ile de
france a remporté ce samedi 4 décembre
la primaire interne du parti face à eric
ciotti c'était lors du congrès élèves
quelles sont les réactions des élus des
yvelines du département où elle est élue
le reportage de grégory canal et la
droite est de retour
et ali vraiment debout les programmes
qui ont été choisis par les adhérents
sont des programmes de droite assumé
pour porter ce projet des républicains
une yvelinoise valérie pécresse est
engagée politiquement depuis de
nombreuses années dans le département
député de la 2e circonscription de 2002
à 2007 puis de 2012 à 2016 la présidente
de la région ile de france est
aujourd'hui élu dans la commune de
vélizy villacoublay un ancrage mise en
avant par les élus locaux dont pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines bravo à
valérie pécresse pour sa belle et
incontestable victoire département le
mieux géré de francs ce les yvelines
propose aux français une yvelinoise
rassemblement pour valérie c'est tout
son coach irakien en fait elle aime
aller au contact et si elle est
aujourd'hui conseiller municipal à
vélizy c'est aussi parce qu'elle avait
envie de se confronter et data en phase
avec la réalité du terrain et c'est vrai
que c'est à ce moment là où on peut se
faire chahuter on peut être challenge
est deuxième à l'issue du premier tour
du congrès ait l'air valérie pécresse
l'a finalement emporté face à eric
ciotti avec 69 95 % des voix plus de 82%
des 140 mille adhérents du parti ont
participé au scrutin si elle a gagné
c'est parce qu'elle avait le meilleur
projet le plus précis
le plus chiffrée est à la fois son
projet quel projet d'une droite assumé
comme le dit assez ferme sur toutes les
questions réelles yens et en même temps
ouverte sur les questions qui sont des
questions parfois peu appréhendé par la
droite je pense notamment à tous les
sujets environnementaux me sujet de deux
familles et puis c'est le choix aussi
d'une personnalité dont on a reconnu la
capacité à fédérer quid désormais de
l'unité dans le parti de droite eric
ciotti a estimé dimanche 4 décembre que
valérie pécresse n'avait pas envoyé un
message de rassemblement lors de son
premier discours de candidate sur
twitter le député des alpes-maritimes a
ensuite affirmé vouloir porter ses idées
en duo avec elle lors de la campagne
présidentielle
l'unité tiendra-t-elle le coup jusqu'à
la présidentielle avec eric zemmour qui
a déjà fait un appel du pied aux
électeurs d'eric ciotti pas d'inquiétude
chez les républicains la barrière
hermétique avec les droites radicales
c'est une réalité qui n'a pas commencé
hier c'était vrai du temps du rpr avec
jacques chirac c'est vrai aujourd'hui
aux républicains et je suis certain eric
ciotti lui sera fidèle à sa famille
politique ce matin valérie pécresse a
fait son premier déplacement chez eric
ciotti alliera chez xavier bertrand
vendredi il faut bien se rappeler
quelque chose c'est qu'on a tous envie
de gagner en avril prochain en 2017
c'est françois fillon qui avait porté la
candidature ait l'air empêtré dans
plusieurs affaires judiciaires il
s'était classé troisième du premier tour
avec 20% des suffrages derrière emmanuel
macron et marine le pen
une yvelinoise donc candidate aux
élections présidentielles de 2022
valérie pécresse vous l'avez entendu a
remporté donc le congrès les
républicains avec 60% des voix des
adhérents du parti contre 40% pour eric
ciotti présidente de région ministres
députés retour sur son parcours aux
politiques avec nicolas landry
elle restera la première femme candidate
de la droite gouvernementale à une
élection présidentielle valérie pécresse
représentera les républicains lors du
scrutin présidentiel de 2022 une
responsabilité obtenu le samedi 4
décembre au congrès du parti en
récoltant 60% des voix devant eric
ciotti l'heure est maintenant à l'union
de la droite notre rassemblement je veux
l'étendre à toutes les figures et les
talents de la droite les talents du
centre mais aussi les talents d'ailleurs
à tous les républicains sincères qui se
reconnaîtront dans notre projet pour la
france en juin dernier valérie pécresse
est réélue présidente de la région ile
de france une victoire avec près de 60%
des suffrages au second tour des
élections régionales largement devant
l'union de la gauche à plus de 33 % lors
de l'installation du conseil régional
elle parlait déjà de sa vision de la
france j'appelle à une france nouvelle
irrigué par ces territoires oxygénée par
ces provinces une france vraiment
décentralisée libéré
une france où l'état assurerait
puissamment ses responsabilités
régaliennes car la sécurité pardon de le
dire c'est une tautologie c'est d'abord
l'état à 54 ans valérie pécresse et à la
tête de l'exécutif régional depuis 2015
suite à ces nouvelles fonctions elle
démissionne de son siège de député de la
2e circonscription des yvelines en 2016
un mandat exercé depuis 2002 durant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy elle a
occupé plusieurs fonctions
gouvernementales
d'abord ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur en portant la réforme de
l'autonomie des universités puis
ministre du budget et porte-parole du
gouvernement
l'autonomie c'est plus de liberté pour
les universités de faire des innovations
pédagogiques
de nouer des partenariats y compris avec
les entreprises pour la réussite des
élèves mais c'est surtout une culture du
résultat et de la performance
sorti de l'école nationale de
l'administration elle entre au conseil
d'état avant de devenir conseillère de
jacques chirac à l'elysée avec un
parcours politique locale et nationale
elle veut devenir la première femme
présidente de la république
pour cela un énorme défi l'attend faire
la synthèse de l'électorat du centre
jusqu'à la droite conservatrice tout en
convaincant les abstentionnistes et pour
continuer sur le sujet patrick stefanini
vous êtes avec nous bonsoir bon bonjour
vous êtes le directeur de campagne de
valérie pécresse alors qu'elle est déjà
votre réaction est ce qu'on s'y
attendait finalement
il n'y avait pas vraiment on peut pas
dire que valérie était favorite
elle s'est plutôt
après avoir mené une campagne de terrain
très intense elle s'est imposée dans les
débats notamment lors du deuxième débat
et ensuite elle n'a plus rien lâché et
comme vous l'avez vu les résultats du
premier tour ont été très serrés mais
lui ont permis de se qualifier pour la
finale et ensuite
en face d'eric ciotti
il était clair que valérie pécresse
avait de très grandes chances de
l'emporter et donc là le prochain
objectif finalement donc c'est les
élections présidentielles vous en tant
que directeur de campagne vous êtes en
charge forcément de la stratégie à
adopter comment on se prépare et
justement qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour cette campagne
alors on va faire plusieurs choses
d'abord valérie là dit elle a
l'intention de faire une équipe très
solide en s'appuyant en priorité sur les
personnalités qui ont été ses rivaux ses
rivaux malheureux tant au premier qu'au
second tour mais qui évidemment ont été
appréciés par les français notamment
dans la phase des débats pour certains
d'entre eux je pense à philippe juvin et
dans une moindre mesure à exotiques qui
ont été découverts par les adhérents des
républicains à l'occasion de ces de ces
débats à l'échelle nationale et donc
valérie pécresse va s'appuyer sur ces
quatre personnalités et formé autour
d'elle en rassemblant toutes les
personnalités des républicains une
équipe solide comme vous le savez elle
avait par ailleurs d'ores et déjà le
soutien d'hervé morin
et donc du nouveau centre
reste la question des discussions à
avoir avec avec lui dit mais nous avons
l'habitude la la quasi-totalité des
personnalités qui en france dirige des
départements ou des régions et qui sont
à droite le fond en gouvernance et
département où ces régions avec des élus
sans étiquette ou avec des élus du
centre
dont valérie pécresse va construire le
même type d'alliance politique son
projet son projet est bien avancé
mais il reste un certain nombre de
choses à préciser comme elle l'a dit
elle même il y a des choses qu'elle n'a
pas proposé et qu'on trouve dans les
projets de ses concurrents et donc nous
allons dans l'est dans les quatre cinq
semaines qui viennent
enrichir son projet elle va elle-même y
contribuer puissamment puisque comme
vous l'avez compris elle va poursuivre
son dialogue avec les françaises et les
français n'ont pas en organisant des
grands meetings dans une période où le
contexte sanitaire ne s'y prête
absolument pas mais en allant à la
rencontre des françaises et des français
d'abord dans les départements
dans les dents ses rivaux lors de la
primaire sont les élus elle est
aujourd'hui à nice nice et dans les
alpes maritimes chez eric ciotti il sera
en savoir avec michel barnier jeudi dans
le nord avec xavier bertrand vendredi
elle sera demain dans les hauts-de-seine
avec avec philippe jupe voilà donc
constitution de l'équipe
monte en puissance du projet en
l'enrichissant à la fois
de tout ce que valérie pécresse va
entendre au contact des françaises et
des français et des bonnes idées à
prendre dans les projets de michel
barnier de xavier bertrand et d'eric
ciotti et philippe juba voilà voilà le
programme et est justement pour parler
un peu des convictions de madame valérie
pécresse comment finalement pour faire
un test l'attestent comme vous disiez la
synthèse pardon entre les idées des
quatre candidats et de rester sur ses
convictions à elle
valérie pécresse a des convictions
extrêmement ferme sur les questions du
régalien sur les questions de sécurité
sur les questions d'immigration elle
veut sur lens en expression remettre de
l'ordre dans la rue c'est l'aspiration
première de nos concitoyens tous les
sondages le démontrent mais le programme
de valérie pécresse ne repose pas
uniquement sur le régalien elle a
formulé des propositions
sur les sujets économiques
comme vous le savez elles considèrent et
elle l'a dit à plusieurs reprises qu'ils
emmanuel macron avec ramé la caisse et
qu'il faudrait veiller dans la période
actuelle à rétablir les équilibres des
finances publiques pas évidemment du
jour au lendemain il faut avoir une
gestion responsable
nous sommes ici dans un département
département des yvelines où le président
pierre bédier a choisi de faire du
département des yvelines
un détail le département qui investit le
plus de tous les départements français
quand on rapporte le budget
d'investissement à la population du
département et al'inverse un des
départements un des trois départements
de france
où on dépense le moins en fonctionnement
et bien valérie pécresse partage cette
philosophie de ce que doit être la
dépense publique dans notre pays elle
doit être axé en priorité sur
l'investissement et il faut une gestion
particulièrement rigoureuse des dépenses
de fonctionnement pour autant à valérie
pécresse n'oublie pas les questions de
pouvoir d'achat auquel beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
modeste et a fortiori fragiles sont
confrontés qu'ils s'agissent donc des
salariés modestes qu'il s'agisse d'une
partie des classes moyennes qu'il
s'agisse des retraités qui sont
confrontés à des problèmes considérables
de pouvoir d'achat et valérie pécresse
aura le souci elle a déjà commencé à le
faire avec sa proposition d'augmentation
de 10% des salaires nets pour tous les
titulaires d'un salaire inférieur à 2,2
smic mais elle aura à coeur dans les
semaines qui viennent d'accentuer ses
propositions dans ce domaine de façon à
s'adresser résolument à l'électorat
populaire et et aux classes moyennes et
puis on est enfin valérie pécresse de
tous les candidats qui se sont présentés
à cette primaire est celle qui a le
programme le plus développé le plus
costaud en ce qui concerne
l'environnement la protection de
l'environnement l'écologie et on sait
que ces enjeux compte aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui sont
parfaitement informés de ce qu'on
appelle le défi climatique et on sait
que ces enjeux compte encore plus pour
un électorat
qui a déserté la droite depuis plusieurs
années mais qui est en train d'y revenir
c'est l'électorat jeune et avec
l'électorat populaire et l'électorat des
classes moyennes l'électorat jeune sera
une des priorités de valérie pécresse
parce que c'était panini peut-être
brièvement parce que nous n'avons plus
beaucoup de temps mais un petit mot sur
justement vous parlez des idées de
madame pécresse pour la compagne comment
on fait finalement pour faire cette
balance entre essayer de se recentrer un
petit peu sans perdre les électeurs de
droite finalement on est on est comme
les valérie pécresse très ferme sur le
régalien et pas seulement ferme en
paroles parce que la désignation d'une
femme pour la première fois dans
l'histoire du mouvement gaulliste pour
l'élection présidentielle c'est
évidemment une nouvelle quelque chose
d'inédit mais la politique c'est pas
genre et ce qui est intéressant dans la
désignation de valérie pécresse s'est
pas seulement qu'elle est une femme mais
que c'est une femme courageuse une femme
déterminée avec un mental d'acier et ça
à sa formule la formule qui nous a
permis je croise l'emporter dans cette
primaire c'est le courage de dire et la
volonté de faire madame pécresse est une
femme d'action sur les sujets régaliens
elle est extrêmement ferme est là elle a
rédigé deux proposent ils de projet de
loi constitutionnelle l'un sur
l'immigration l'autre sur la sécurité
intérieure et la lutte contre
l'islamisme et donc ça c'est pour la
droite et pour l'ailé gauche ou en tout
cas pour le reste de l'opinion publique
on va s'adresser à la classe moyenne à
l'électorat populaire et à la jeunesse
merci beaucoup patrick stefanini d'avoir
été avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
donc le directeur de campagne de madame
valérie pécresse merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et on reste dans les élections mais
cette fois ci il s'agit des élections
municipales partielles de louveciennes
un scrutin qui fait suite au passage de
plusieurs conseillers du côté de
l'opposition et de la démission du reste
de l'équipe municipale le premier tour
s'est déroulé ce dimanche 5 décembre
pour ce qui est des résultats
marie-dominique parisot et sa liste
réussir louveciennes ensemble arrive en
tête du scrutin avec 48 % du suffrage
elle est suivie par pierre françois
wiart le maire sortant il obtient 38 %
des voix pour sa liste avec vous pour
l'ancien le candidat de la gauche pascal
leprêtre se qualifie aussi pour le
second tour avec 10 % des voix et sa
liste louveciennes écologique citoyenne
et solidaire et puis avec près de 3%
pierre ferret tête de liste du bon sens
pour lucian ne participera pas au second
tour second tour qui aura lieu ce
dimanche 12 décembre
et on parle à présent du côté du futur
centre aqualudique de maurepas et long
cours la ministre déléguée elle chargée
des sports roxana maracineanu
où s'est rendu sur place ce lundi 6
décembre en projet depuis 2015 il sera
implanté à la place de l'ancienne
piscine maurepas sienne qui avait été
détruite pour cause de sécurité
apprentissage de la natation baignade
sport santé vous bien être l'espace de
cinq bassins se veut accessible à tous
les explications de cmt charles la
ministre des sports oksana maracineanu
est venue symboliquement posé sa pierre
à l'édifice au centre castagna ce lundi
6 décembre héritier de l'ancienne
piscine de maurepas fermer en 2015 ce
centre aquatique aujourd'hui dans la
phase importante de la pause des bassins
est pensé et dimensionné pour répondre à
tous les besoins des habitants c'est
toujours un plaisir pour moi en tant que
ministre des sports et ancienne nageuse
olympique de venir voir comment une
piscine va sortir de terre un lieu où on
pourra apprendre à nager on pourra se
détendre également puisque on aura
fitness sera du sauna hammam et puis de
l'activité pour s'amuser puisqu'il y
aura toboggan numérique bref un
équipement qui soit adaptée à tous les
centres aquatiques sur un territoire et
l'équipement public qui réunit toutes
les générations
véritable projet structurant pour le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
un objectif ressort du lot lutter contre
les noyades chez les jeunes il y a mille
décès par an par noyade et le quart
concerne les enfants de moins de 6 ans
on agisse au plus près des familles un
espace construit dans une logique de
transition écologique avec des matériaux
durables et responsables et un bâtiment
intégré dans son environnement penser
développement durable de penser
transition énergétique et cet équipement
à la fois ce conte est compact sa
filtration billes de verre c'est qu'on
n'aura pas les désordres de l'équipement
passé le fait aussi d'avoir un
partenariat avec récré à une délégation
de service public le partenaire aura
l'obligation d'entretenir et de faire
les travaux sur l'équipement pendant 25
ans un centre aqualudique innovants pour
petits et grands qui devrait ouvrir en
septembre 2022
créé en 2013 le club climat énergie de
saint quentin en yvelines a pour
vocation est de réfléchir à une
mutualisation des sujets autour de la
transition énergétique sur le territoire
dont ce but une conférence sera animée
demain mardi 7 décembre à l'estaca à
montigny le bretonneux et xavier de la
porte fondateur du club climat énergie
vous la présente son interview express
de la part de bixente meilleure santé
steban regarder
[Musique]
vous accompagnons le territoire depuis
huit ans sur différentes thématiques la
mobilité la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments la transition écologique la
méthanisation ou les énergies
renouvelables ou le plus récemment
l'autoconsommation de l'énergie qui soit
auto produites par les par différents
types d'acteurs
il s'agira de mini débat
avec qui seront modérées par différents
acteurs et duclos climat énergie leur
permettant à chacun de s'exprimer sur
leurs positions qu'elle soit du niveau
du territoire où qu'elle soit du niveau
des acteurs ou expert de la société
civile
[Musique]
pour le collège je reçois monsieur
laurent merckaert de ce genre à
thessalonique eva roussel et bertrand
coq a requis par ailleurs et le
président du club climat énergie chacun
pourra débattre avec un acteur de la
société civile pour échanger sur les
thématiques comme le numérique
l'aménagement du territoire les
mobilités et les circuits courts
c'est de mettre des projets de manière
collaborative c'est bien finalement
plutôt de déposer une réflexion unique
sourd à la manière de concevoir une
solution nous la faisons partager par un
ensemble d'acteurs et quelque part
autour de ces réflexions là nous
essayons de remonter ce qui est bon pour
le consommateur
ce week end c'était la 35e édition du
téléthon plusieurs animations avaient
lieu dans le département pour récolter
des fonds pour la recherche célia gars
tsongo et patrick jacques de dixmude eux
se sont rendus à magny les hameaux et à
versailles pour l'occasion regard des
rouge et blanc les couleurs du pays
basque le sud-ouest étaient à l'honneur
à magny les hameaux pour le téléthon 35e
édition au gymnase chantal mauduit dans
une ambiance festive l'association
objectif téléthon manie quoi créer
depuis 14 ans organise chaque année le
téléthon pour récolter des fonds de
milliers de personnes qui vont venir en
fait pendant ces 24 25 heures
il vient de faire la fête et on sonne
enfin et tout la consommation est
intégralement reversé donc c'est avant
tout une opération de voler les festives
au programme de nombreuses animations
basket tir à l'arc ou encore pétanque
les amateurs pouvaient découvrir une
planche qui appartenait à philippe
quintais champion du monde de pétanque
c'est un monsieur qui nous donne envie
de continuer justement la pétanque et et
en espérant que les jeux qu'on fait ce
soir puisse attirer des jeunes à suivre
son exemple ce sont dix sept mille cinq
cents euros qui ont été collectés durant
ce week end autre ambiance à versailles
le pâté en croûte et est le produit
phare pour le téléthon depuis 24 ans le
lions club de versailles et la
charcuterie les délices du palais
s'associent pour réaliser le record du
monde du plus grand pâté en croûte cette
année il fait près de 70 m la frange est
à 3 euros depuis le lancement mais les
gens donnent souvent beaucoup plus un
euro collecté est intégralement reversé
au téléthon il faut compter 96 heures de
fabrication ça fait 20 ans que tous les
shaks téléthon je vais chercher mon pâté
en croûte il est très bon c'est sur le
plan gastronomique et une veut le faire
et qu'ils ont plus ça aide des gens
comme on vraiment besoin trouve que
c'est une très bonne initiative
donc les produits sont bons et en plus
c'est protéger ton chaque année entre
8000 à 9000 euros par an sont collectées
par les ventes de pâté en croûte plus de
700000 euros ont été récoltés dans les
yvelines
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis dans un instant
retrouver un mickaël hay et demi d'euros
la présentation de votre magazine
sportif il sera accompagné de bixente
mais rien senti steban pour vos
résultats du week end et puis nous on se
quitte avec les images du marché de noël
de montigny le bretonneux qui avait lieu
ce week end à la ferme du manet onze
mille six cents personnes se sont
rendues sur place ils ont pu profiter
des 130 stands d'artisanat d'art et de
spécialités régionales très bonne soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]